Fabby congratulations a labored victory
for you this was not easy it looked easy
at one point as you were approaching
that time travel situations those last
couple of moves before the new time
control but it felt like he got back
into the game how did you recover from
that and start a new this attempt at
winning the
game yeah I I think I was winning at
some point very clearly because he he
went for a very strange decision um I
didn't really understand why he played
D5 it wasn't necessary I think although
the position is of course a mess but
yeah D5 was a very strange choice to my
mind and then I thought that I I have a
huge Advantage uh you did but maybe I I
I captured on A4 prematurely I'm I'm not
sure yeah this this just looks crushing
I mean yeah taking on A4 was was just
very impractical I should the Pawn's not
running anywhere I can play Queen G6 and
uh later I realized like why don't I
just play Queen G6 and if King H2 then I
could take the pawn or I can even play
H6 because he's actually in in
Domination uh okay Rook A1 is of course
not what you want but I I I was a bit
too direct um and I kind of thought that
this position after Queen E6 would be
winning which maybe it is but then it it
it became yeah here I thought there's
there must be something Queen D7 Bishop
B6 I just didn't see it I I felt like
there's something here but I couldn't
quite uh quite see it uh not that clear
yeah Knight c yeah not that clear I
wouldn't say this is clear Queen E1 and
Bishop F3 yeah but then fig4 this is not
not
obvious yeah it's like I'm not mating
him directly so it's you know it's a
little bit difficult to sacrifice my
queenside pawns when I felt like if I
kept them I should also be much better
at winning but then I lost control
completely I he was hanging in very well
yeah I I just okay every move is a
blunder
yeah it's it's funny Bishop E4 is a
mistake right it's so natural to play
Bishop E4 but it's like seems to be the
best move good luck playing Knight E8
with 20 seconds on the clock it makes no
sense but B5 maybe just start pushing
the pawns right but I I didn't want to
allow Rook d8 that's the only thing I
didn't want to misplace either I guess
the thing is the Knight on E8 is
actually very decent yeah which I didn't
realize I just didn't want to put it
there uh but he is kind of getting
checkmated in many lines or maybe I just
push my pawns and uh and he he can't he
can't really defend against that because
his King is chronically weak then once
he got F3 I think it's a complete mess
again um you know in fact I was a little
bit happy that he played like this G4
because after Bishop D3 I it's it's kind
of a double-edged position after G4 yeah
Queen C5 Rook D3 okay we get a technical
end game it's either a draw or uh yeah
probably it's a draw but I I don't risk
anything um and with the time control
being so unforgiving at least here okay
it's nice to have that uh playing for
two results situation rather than
playing a very messy position down in
exchange and yeah then it was a a clear
clear draw for sure at some
point at this point you were making some
I saw
Queen I saw Queen C7 after Queen A4 but
I thought F4 I didn't see how to
continue C7 here you mean where no no
not not here there's a moment when I
played
H5 okay when he played H5 yes Queen to
C7 right now yeah here so I have Queen
C7 F4 Queen B6 King F3 I didn't see how
to how to do it it's only like he has
only squares Queen B7 King E3
mhm Queen G2 Queen A7 King I I can hide
from checks like
this really it doesn't yeah I'm not sure
it doesn't feel like I'm hiding but
somehow Queen B8 Queen G8 Queen
E5 yeah you know when when he went for
this uh I really thought Queen is like
my first instinct was Queen C7 he
resigns and then I saw this F4 and I was
trying to make some checks work but I
couldn't so I just gave up on the idea
uh but maybe it's yeah I guess this was
winning uh and and I think he I thought
very at this point after
H3 Queen to G7 instead of king queen to
f8 queen to
F6 try to stop you from going to
E5 yeah you know King E7 was kind of a
random move I was like I can't make
Queen I couldn't make Queen D6 work I
couldn't figure it out because King G4 I
didn't see how to continue and I thought
okay King E7 he's low on time I'll
confuse him with this move which he
doesn't expect which is probably a bad
move King G4 like what's Queen A6 but I
thought Queen B3 I saw this queen G7
Queen C3 I thought how do I hide again
Queen
F6 Queen C7 King
h8 I on H7 yeah I have checks on G7 yeah
yeah okay I was missing missing a lot of
things yeah okay this queen end games
are extremely difficult uh Fabi still a
very important victory for you the first
victory in the tournament for you very
important because uh one ABI Manu only
14 years of age is running away uh
scoring a lot of Victories already uh
what do you think of his
performance yeah I guess he's uh well
he's some sort of
Genius some sort I mean uh he's uh yeah
the these little kids are are really
dangerous I remember also also last year
like uh the kids are coming and uh
they're causing us a lot of trouble like
last year Wesley Wesley lost to um
Christopher to Christopher right yeah
yeah it's you you really can't
underestimate them because they're you
think they're young and they they don't
know much compared to okay we've been
playing chess for forever of course we
know a lot more but they they work very
hard they calculate well uh
I mean obviously uh Misha is is a really
really strong player already despite his
his young age um so definitely not to be
underestimated absolutely our
congratulations Fabby get yourself some
rest and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you absolutely as we have
one game remaining